[Music]
are you cutting and editing this just
because we're looking through it
who's the best teammate in training
cameron
by far
it's playable
competition
what's your favorite srs product and
what's your favorite flavor
the nootropics gel gets you going all
right it's got definitely a good kick
yeah
who's the fussiest eater on the team
our fussiest would probably be big man
he's always super judgmental of what you
have on your plate and
if you don't finish your food
yeah he's probably the most judgmental
either definitely
describe what the setup is like at the
team hotel
so
at the minute we've got single rooms
as you know uh
and each individual person's responsible
for our room mine's pretty tidy yours is
probably a mess
but uh
yeah and then obviously we've got our
own dining area coffee machine
and it's just a bit of full narrative
you know keep that simple it's not so
bad also with the chef
he's not too bad
how do you relax and reset between races
yeah it's pretty much just
yeah putting your feet up um
watching a good show um
calling the family seeing how some
friends are
or
having some friendly dancer with you
guys
maybe playing a chess match here now or
losing a chess match
all right
what do you eat before a typical rice
uh
it depends what we're doing if it's uh
like the classics yeah eat as much as
you can really you know especially when
we've got the chef here
makes amazing food yeah it's almost hard
not to eat too much you know
but anything pasta rice whatever's out
there but for everything
what tv series you're watching right now
i just finished the drive to survive the
latest season alright
i'm really looking forward to next
season uh
or also the one that they're going to do
on the tour de france but
i haven't seen any good shows lately
other than that one
you got a pretty good one there so you
know
what's your favorite post-race meal i
feel you a lot about food at the minute
are you hungry or something i just came
off lunch yeah favorite post-race meal
i don't know we had burgers last night
was it last time no no after
dwelling not pizza
i think pizza's a bit
you're sort of a bit hotter you know all
right but
big beer as well would be nice
you